hello everyone I'm Felipe Hoffa Google
cloud developer advocate and today I'm
in Johannesburg South Africa to meet the
city of nominee Dell happy this company
enables microtransactions in various
countries around Africa with these
devices they create their is going to
tell us more about their story and why
they chose to build their backbone with
Google cloud also will show you how you
can use open data and bigquery to
visualize the state of the moral
networks that connect the world so join
me with my first time in South Africa
and I think there's so much we can learn
about Africa just by looking at what
you're doing not only South Africa but
Africa that's correct
so what nominee does is we do both
point-of-sale systems to help remote
villages get access to prepaid airtime
prepaid electricity and basic banking
services like being able to withdraw
deposit cash now and run in according to
this business we have to help people yes
back in 2011 when we started the company
we focused a lot more on airtime we
wanted to get scratchcards out into
rural villages but it's very difficult
and expensive to send boxes of scratch
cards which are worth money in to
far-flung villages and then collect cash
and bring it back to the cities and to
pay for those that airtime
if you wirelessly deliver airtime these
vouchers to machines that are in the
village it's a lot cheaper and more
cost-effective so people in the villages
who don't have a lot of money to start
with don't have to travel far to go get
the essential services like airtime or
electricity or and now even banking
services so I visit the of nominee you
created a lot of the devices back in
2011 yes we started off with the
terminal it was very simple to use no
screen just some buttons where you press
the mobile network like Vodafone and you
press the 10
denomination or having many mighty cash
where we are and the continent and it
prints out a slip and you got a PIN
number that you type into your phone and
then you've started with the cloud back
in 2011 yeah before I joined mama Nene I
had my own company and we were doing the
early days of Internet of Things and I
absolutely fell in love with App Engine
because I'm more of an embedded system
guy so what I knew back then about
setting up high availability service was
a bit scary so App Engine solved my
problem and then when I joined no me
Nene I took that knowledge with me and
we built up our systems back in that
does all the transaction processing and
the maintenance and monitoring of all
these devices on App Engine now to be
able to pull this off you need to have a
network connectivity yes that's correct
I have that looking in Africa um so each
of our devices has a SIM card in and
that links up to the network and a cause
a REST API on our system but the
networks while they're there there can
be a little bit flaky so getting this
knowing what the signal strength is is
very important for us how can I learn
more about well there's a project called
the open cell ID project and people with
gps's and their and data monitors
typically tracking companies take their
data and anonymize it and upload it to
this open source project called open
cell ID and this project then takes that
data and figures out where all the base
stations are around the world can you
show me that absolutely yeah so I've got
this page open here this is the open
cell ID page and you can see all the
those base stations around the world
that they've collected data for I've
registered on the API so if I log in
then I can go to download and can
download the latest cell tower data from
this link and what I did is I didn't
want to download it onto my laptop and
then re-upload it into Google Cloud
storage or bigquery
so I spun up an f-1 micro which is a
free instance
and I used curl to download that the
file which is about 800 Meg's or so and
then from there I used gsutil to upload
it from the f1 micro instance into
Google Cloud storage so here you can see
that self-interests 886 Meg's of gzip
data and if you want to analyze this
yeah it's not very is just like sitting
in Google Cloud storage so I used
bigquery so one of my favorite tools
with bigquery for importing or creating
a table is you can point it straight at
a Google Cloud Storage bucket and you
can use appointed to a gzip file you
don't even need to worry about unzipping
at first at all its of CSV format and I
know all the columns that are um fancy
yeah radio so it's like GSM or LTE MCC
move our country codes
that's the country that is in the
network is the like photo comm MTN
whatever areas like the suburb and cell
is the unique cell ID and from there I
imported it so I've got this data here
so you can see all the columns are
imported and never look at the details
it's a four gig so it went from 880
Meg's
two gigabytes decompressed and it's got
just shy of 40 million unique base
stations from around the world
I can then have a look at for instance
this one is finding out the latitude and
the longitude and the radio type so
having a look at basically where's GSM
where is the LTE networks like how is
the world moving from first and second
and third and fourth gen cell phone
towers so running this query everyone
gain so the rupee here by grouping it by
the latitude alone the latitude and the
longitude so that's just doing some
rounding with the division there just so
we don't get too many data points and
then looking at the case when it's GSM
or LTE and then importing that or at
least visualizing that inside of data
studio so it took those four Network
types that they recorded CDMA which is
the primarily you can see the used in
the US
and some in the East the world has moved
on to GSM so throughout the world
we've still got we've got GSM every way
and you can see particularly in Africa
is huge amount of coverage with gsm
networks there then we move over to
third gentes as like your 3g data
obviously also widely rolled out but
less so in Africa but there's still
quite a lot of 3G available and then we
move over to the fourth gen networks so
LTE also some in Africa mostly in the
big cities and huge in the East so LTE
is big there the Africa's got some
catching up to do and that took me about
five minutes to do I finally you
downloaded all of this data you loaded
into bigquery and suddenly we're looking
at the whole world o antennas are
looping that's right nice can we focus
on Africa what else can you see about
Africa what I had a look at was given
the mobile country codes
that's the MCC that's the MCC the mobile
country code sir each country has a
unique code like South Africa's is six
five five and we did a join with the
mobile country codes with country names
so there's a database that has all the
country names in the country code and
then doing a count to have a look at how
many antennas unique base stations or
every country in the world and taking
that and I wanted to explore that a
little bit more so putting in the ISO
code which is the like as a day for
South Africa or GB for Great Britain or
Puerto Rico PR and then going even one
step further joining that with one of
Google's country info databases that's
available on the internet so having a
look at population data versus how many
antennas and seeing is there a
correlation between population size and
how much a mobile network has rolled out
how many antenna flew we have there
people exactly and that's this division
here the number of antennas per capita
so for and this is actually per thousand
people so like Australia has got 17
antennas for 1000 people right so if we
once again go into Data studio we can
have a look at what that looks like
across
Africa and if we plot that on a log-log
scale of the total antennas versus the
total population we can have a look at
see with the big countries it's so it
correlates with having lots of mobile
base stations and the smaller countries
with less population have fewer bases
which sort of makes sense so there's
this linear trend and but you still see
a big disparity but some countries have
a lot of antennas that's right like if
you look this is a log scale so we have
a look at the country like the
Seychelles it's got very few people and
at eighty eight thousand but they've got
you know just under a thousand antennas
there and other countries like Chad
which is right in the middle of the
light spot now they've got quite a high
population but not widely rolled out
mobile network and the countries that
have you know in South Africa Nigeria
Egypt and you look up at the top here
there's Nigeria Egypt South Africa so
for South Africa's population of just
under 50 million people we've got the
most widely rolled out mobile network in
Africa and in which country the nominee
is operating in a little bit in South
Africa but mostly in Mozambique and
Zambia and Kenya and a little bit in
Ghana as well and here you can get a
look of where you are rig getting real
cover it's like reported by people
that's right yeah and then you can take
all of this later this is public data
and you can combine it with your own
data yes so we have a bunch of
diagnostic data that's uploaded to our
systems so if I have a look at one of
ours as a particular user in Mozambique
every minute we're just uploading
diagnostic information everything from
user interfaces to here we've got the
latitude and longitude of the GPS and
importantly the cell phone diagnostic
information the signal strength and then
we do a survey of the seven surrounding
base stations looking at what the signal
strength is of the surrounding
as well all of these devices that you
have deployed are reporting you what's
happening that's right and right where
they are so if a client foreign services
my my phone isn't connecting or my
devices and connecting I can't use your
system then we can do an investigation
and understand I give it a signal
problem or is there some other problem
yeah I mean you are getting this later
now into kubernetes how are you yes sir
all the data the data is uploaded from
the devices to our service so some of it
is an app engine and some of it is in
Cuba Nexus and from there it's streamed
live into bigquery so that's what we use
for some of our analyses so if I look at
selecting the data from one of our
clients for today we've got a ton of
data that's been uploaded already and I
can go and look specifically for
something like this GSM environment so
environments for one of our clients
frozen beak so now I can have a look at
all of today's data and what we've got
is this raw diagnostics that's being
uploaded but you know unless you're a
mobile network engineer this doesn't
mean a lot to you right so yeah this is
in bigquery and then doing I can use big
queries this is in JSON I can use JSON
methods within bigquery
I can split on commas I can pull out
very specific pieces of this information
like this is the country code and the
network code and the base station IDs as
well as all the signal strength for all
these base stations so the other ways I
see you have like a big JSON blob of
whatever the advice of attending that's
right that's good Molly yeah so a lot of
our data is Jason especially for this
particular table which is a sty event
log
it just takes raw data there's no detail
or anything on it it's just whatever the
device or the engineers who build these
devices or developers and make the app
just want to send up we send up and put
it into bigquery and then later on once
we've got all the data we can decide
what sort of questions we won
and because it's in Jason and bigquery
can operate on Jason so nicely and we
can extract just the pieces of
information that we want and build new
data tables over that next you compare
all of that in real time exactly
whatever you want to focus that's right
then from there what I've done is I've
pulled out for all of these those each
each row here has got seven diagnostic
readings in it so whatever the more than
we've thrown you yes it's telling me all
these signal strings and the base
station so what I did is I ran one of
these queries to extract from Jason and
got the time the device that uploaded it
the area so I've that's the like the
suburb I guess a suburb ID and then the
cell tower that is connected to as well
as the signal strength so closer it is
to zero is the better the signal
strength is if it's a minus a hundred
it's pretty bad you're not gonna be able
to do anything
so the revived north to what felt I was
gonna exactly but have no idea whether
this cell tower if located that's right
so if a client finds a serpent's is hey
you know I don't have good signal can
you see what the problem is it allows us
to have a look at the device and have a
look at the signal strength that it's
receiving as well as then join that to
the cell the open cell ID towers so
given this I'm doing a join on the cell
ID from between the towers databases and
our devices database and we know to join
and what we get is for each cell we get
the latitude and longitude of where that
base station is as well as the maximum
the minimum and the average signal
strength that our clients are
experiencing on that cell tower and from
that we can put it into a dashboard and
this is all the cell towers that we've
connected to in Maputo so that's the
capital of Mozambique with Aviv readers
yes it is 3 - I love leaders it's super
for during the sort of geovisualization
so you see largely this is green which
is good it means like the cell towers
I've got good signal scheme the cabbie
Bella for the capital of Mozambique yeah
but this one device that I show
your devices these are our devices yeah
if we look at this guy his in Maputo
but he is sort of a little bit to the
north of the city so we we have a look
in reed ash here in the north of the
city where he is his gots you know it's
a bit of yellow and red so we can
explore down and see that there is a
cellphone tower that has not got a great
signal strength and because we've got
the cell tower
we can then phone up the mobile network
and say that in this particular area
this space station has a very poor
signal strength for our users could they
fix it well so you can use your own data
to tell the network where they have
problems yes because they're not gonna
report it to you yeah but if we can give
them data that like then they then have
fixed stuff before well I would love to
learn more about how you're managing
micropayments all over Africa but let's
save that for another episode absolutely
excellent so thank you everyone for
joining aft Thank You Dale thank you for
having me
and everyone stay curious I'll see you
soon